i saw this article about the fact that
many leaders are afraid to share their
opinions today publicly
ceos executive did you see that article
ceos executives it's like listen i'm
better off just not saying anything even
though i agree with them if you look at
this post tyler if we can put this up
difference between being public and
private opinions right so you look at
right there this is from june 8th it's a
survey of 3334 american adults conducted
may 23rd to june 8.
ceos should take a stand on
controversial social issues 14 privately
agree 28 publicly agree
public schools focus too much on racism
in the u.s 33 percent privately agree
43 publicly agree this used to be a
bigger percentage where we publicly
agreed
mask wearing was effective to stop cover
19. 47 publicly agree
59 pri i'm sorry 47 privately 59
publicly discussing gender identity in
public schools is inappropriate for k-3
children
50 53
privately agree
63 publicly agree abortion should be
left up to a woman and her doctor 58 67
and and when you go down and look at
this
one of the things that we become because
when i got into business one of my
mentors gave me some advice he said look
there's three things you should never
talk about
with people don't talk politics don't
talk religion and don't talk personal
live sex things like that i'm like okay
and guess what we like to talk about i
like to debate god i like to debate
politics and i like to debate marriage
relationship sex all that stuff because
it's a big part of our lives but it's a
form of silencing so how much risk do
leaders have today
for because by the way but i i sat down
with a youtuber last week 4 million
subscribers player in the marketplace
and one of the questions he asks is
when did you get comfortable talking
about politics
and i said just so you know i know what
you're thinking because in the youtube
world
you know when they see somebody talking
about issues that really matter they're
like oh that guy's about to lose
everything he's got because you're not
supposed to talk about it he had such a
big brand with business and
entrepreneurship look he's about to lose
it because he's touching these subjects
he's going to lose an audience all this
other stuff okay the alternative to me
of being silenced i just can't live with
that i live like that for 10 years in
iran it's not part of my dna to do that
it's the reason why we're in america
it's the reason why i started a business
it's the reason why i'm a capitalist
right
why do you think so many leaders
today are afraid to publicly discuss
important issues
that both themselves their families are
being impacted and the people at their
workplace well because there are
consequences for it there's no question
about that
but
remember
as our national anthem says in the end
of the first answer
the home of the brave
the land of the land of the free
you can't be the land of the free if
you're not the home of the prey
so unless you're actually willing to
stand up for what you believe in
uh your freedom is going to be gradually
eroded and that's been the history of
societies throughout the history of the
world
the united states
has been different up until now
and i say this is probably the most
extreme challenge
to who we are
that we have ever had right now
and uh we're on the precipice of
deciding which way we're gonna go
are we going to be like
everybody else
or is this truly going to be the shiny
city on the hill
that represents freedom and justice so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]